I don't give a [ __ ] that's how you  didn't do it this is the way we do it  now you don't know every [ __ ] thing  just yet and let's combine in some sort  of Ultron like everybody cares about  top-line numbers impressions followers  people care about dumb [ __ ] data I  think we're living through a very  attractive time to be an entrepreneur  Marc put on a hoodie and a movie came  out and you know Instagram made a  billion dollars after five hundred days  and everybody decided they were an  entrepreneur for every Instagram there's  five million in stash it  we're grossly grossly grossly grossly  grossly under estimating what's  happening I mean listen we're all gonna  become [ __ ] robots Google glass  that's preview [ __ ] we're gonna [ __ ]  I'm gonna put your [ __ ] all on Me we're  gonna be [ __ ] robots and I mean that